de son côté vladimir poutine a évoqué l
efficacité du vaccin russe poutine
devait le président russe affirme qu'il
est prêt à livrer le vaccin aux pays
européens et africains pour lutter
contre la propagation du virus omikron
ans les détails de notre correspondante
à moscou vera goffman la russie pourrait
envoyer son vaccin spoutnik fait
gratuitement dans des pays d'afrique
afin de lutter contre la propagation du
variant au micro du coronavirus a
déclaré le président du fonds
d'investissement direct russe kirill
dmitriev détecté en afrique du sud fin
novembre cette nouvelle souche du coc
vide serait responsable de la flambée
des contaminations en afrique en sic en
europe je vous propose d'écouter les
premières livraisons peuvent être
destinés à des pays africains
en ce moment il y à une violente
épidémie omicron là bas kirill dmitriev
faisait ainsi écho à la déclaration du
président russe vladimir poutine qui
discutaient de la possibilité d'envoyer
le vaccin russe à titre gracieux dans
certains pays avec le premier ministre
russe michael mais justine et la vice
premier ministre tatiana golikova
écoutez spoutnik liège
six autres vaccins solitude les
fonctionne bien selon ce qui est visible
actuellement et d'ici une semaine et
spécialistes donneront leur évaluation
finale probablement même plus efficace
que les autres vaccins utilisés dans le
monde au cours des prochains jours les
experts donneront une évaluation finale
cet égard bien sûr déjà partagé les
médicaments que nous avons je veux dire
également pour le rappel vaccinal
la bouche fermée votre accès
là je peux le paddock
y compris pour les pays européens
c'est bien sûr ils ont un tel besoin et
s'il le souhaite
le vaccin selon nick v est actuellement
en phase d'homologation par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé s'il
n'est toujours pas homologué en europe
août nickelés est autorisée ailleurs
dans 71 pays couvrant une population de
plus de 4 milliards de personnes